this
is star talk cosmic queries edition the
ever popular
cosmic queries and that means i got
chuck nice right next to me virtually
that is virtually yes
you don't even know it uh the calls are
coming from inside the house neil
i'm here i'm here
he's outside the back door he's there
he's getting closer
i'm here i saw that movie that i don't
want that that to
happen so so chuck you got some
questions for us here
again if you're unfamiliar we solicit
questions
from uh in this case our patreon members
they get their questions asked
uh one on one and you got him and i
haven't seen him and if i don't know the
answer i will tell you
to go on to the next question that is
not true so if you don't know
that's not true if you don't know the
answer you're going to tell me something
i'ma tell you something whether or not
it's the answer that's true
you're going to tell me something but
i'll value add
to the question in whatever small way i
promise
you i like it all right okay let's um
okay so uh all of our questions come
from patreon now
people so if you if someone says like
what does space smell like and i say
i don't know what do you smell like
your ways of still addressing the
question i like that
neil degrasse tyson plays the dozens oh
by the way all of our
patreon questions are now just patreon
questions
so if you want to have all of our cosmic
queries questions
thank you did i say all of our patreon
questions okay questions or patreon
questions yes
so by the way people all of our cosmic
queries
questions are drawn from patreon now we
used to
scour the internet and all of our
incarnations
to find out your burning questions but
now
we basically just go to one place and
that's patreon so go to patreon
sign up uh get the get the minimum thing
for
you know uh being a cosmic queries uh
submission and we'll read your question
also just remember that when you do that
you're helping us put this show
on okay so there you have it all right
here's our first question this is uh
wait chuck this is a grab bag right oh
that's right it is a grab bag
which means uh there is no themed
to to there is no theme topic
anything these people want to ask you
they can ask you and we've been trying
to find a name for this
uh uh what i want galactic gumbo
is one i like that that's my favorite
too because now you know why
i don't know of course you know why
because now you know when you put it all
together you
had a little cayenne pepper there you go
so i don't know maybe we'll call it
kitchen sink who knows the kitchen sink
all right give me some kitchens cosmic
kitchen sink so here we go
uh jensen smart wants to know this what
is your favorite star
and why apart from the sun
yeah he knew i was that's what i was
going to give him yeah so it would have
to be beetlejuice
betelgeuse if you want to pronounce it
you know i've heard people say
betel juice and i'm just like it's
betelgeuse
yeah it's it's actually arabic and maybe
i'm not even pronouncing it right but
it's definitely not beetlejuice
okay that's okay i thought it okay
i'ma shut up there but just make sure
you don't say it
three times no twice is okay so
um betelgeuse is one of the two
brightest stars of the constellation
orion
betelgeuse is orion's upper
left armpit basically
and i'm told that if you translate from
the arabic is like armpit of the great
one
and so he variously draws you can call
it a shoulder if armpit grosses you out
but so orion is a hunter and he's
standing there and he's defending
himself against
taurus the bull another constellation up
there in the sky
and that star is a red super giant
and we tell it like we see it in
astrophysics
why do we call it a red supergiant i'm
going to guess it's red
because it's red b because it's big
c because it's super big all right
if you put betelgeuse where the sun is
right now in our own solar system
the earth would be orbiting inside its
surface okay
so we wouldn't big enough for you all
right
so and betelgeuse is a candidate
for supernova uh as it ends its life
it will end stupendously in a titanic
explosion and this sucker will be
visible in broad daylight yeah
so it's just it's a star that's got a
lot going on
and i like stars that have a lot going
on
and this past couple of years
mysteriously betelgeuse dimmed by
two-thirds
okay what's that about within months
this is stars that live
hundreds of thousands and in millions of
years and it
the high mass stars that blow up they
don't live billions of years
all right they only live hundreds of
thousands and millions of years
all right so if something happens within
a short amount of time it's like
whoa what's happening what's going on
and
i took photos of betelgeuse as part of
the whole constellation
and then i i looked at it and i almost
lost my breath
because i had never seen the
constellation with the stars
in that relative brightness my whole
life
betelgeuse is one of the brightest stars
in the constellation then it had dimmed
and became uninteresting and it's like
oh my gosh
the sky is changing and so it's i got a
little spooked
i i got to give it to you if you want if
you're wondering just google
betelgeuse and the all manner of
articles about it dimming it's been
slowly coming back
point is we did not understand why it
dimmed we don't have a model for why it
should dim
and people were worried that maybe it's
ready to ready to blow right
or or that there's somebody has a dimmer
switch
yes of course usually when there's
something in the sky we don't understand
they're the alien explainers that run to
the front of the line i could explain it
there are aliens that were building a
dyson sphere
to block the sunlight so that they can
power their civilization
this would be a sphere that prevents the
light from emptying into
space and collects all of the energy for
their own exploitations
so there's always a person who wants to
tell you aliens did it
when at that moment we don't yet
understand it
um but it's it's come back for most of
its brightness
and so i'm i'm sleeping well at nights
now but over that time i was
i was a little uncomfortable so now
that's dimming
which i'm uncomfortable with now is that
was there anything
transiting to cause the dimming or no
nobody had any
no no that's creepy no yeah it was
completely creepy
some mechanism was going on inside of it
that we haven't modeled and we don't
understand ah that's
that's cool actually yeah it's actually
pretty cool it's actually pretty cool
by the way there are plenty of star by
the way let me make this clear plenty of
stars in the night sky
are called variable stars all right and
they're called variable stars because
chuck uh their intensity raises and
lowers yes it varies right okay
right it varies thank you yeah that's
like like i said that's how we roll so
the uh the plenty of stars that do that
and we call them variable stars
betelgeuse was not among them okay so
that's why
oh man this is so interesting from one
stupid question about what's your
favorite star it's like what's your
favorite color
and you turned it into something
interesting i'm just saying
and you can look at old maps of the
night sky from 500 years ago
and earlier and look at the maps that
they drew of the constellations and
there's orion
and betelgeuse is this juicy bright
thing i mean how do you make something
bright when you're drawing with a pencil
so they put stuff around it just so that
it shows up more visibly
in the line drawing of the constellation
so
you look at those maps and it's like
whoa so now this supernova
uh visible by in broad daylight so
i read somewhere that many people many
people
take it back the person that i was re
was writing this
thought it's possible that the star of
the three wise men
was indeed a supernova that
because the star was visible all the
time
that's why they were able to follow it
because it was always visible
including daytime so is that possible
that that's what it was
so you talk about the star of bethlehem
thank you the star of bethlehem
because you know okay i'm so good at
religion
that the three wise men today we call
them wise guys
maybe hey how you doing
don't be a wise guy hey jesus what's up
what's the problem huh no room at the
end
okay yeah we'll tell you i louie will
take care of it
who told you you couldn't sleep there
huh
we got we know people we who i know
people
we know people jesus it's okay
we got a manger for you down the street
we'll make this happen we'll make good
on this
uh so the three wise guys uh so
yeah so it's a lot written on the star
of bethlehem could it have been a comet
and so when you look back to when jesus
was likely born based on all
information available um and that was
uh around 4 bc anywhere between
sort of two and six bc so people split
the difference
around four bc jesus was not born in
zero in year zero
all right plus there was no year zero
but that's a whole other we'll do an
explainer on that
um we went directly from 1bc
to ad1 all right and there was no year
zero
but because when the calendar that was
set up
to do that the xero had not yet been
invented oh
matt thank you as i'm saying it's a
whole we we'll make an explainer out of
that one okay
but here's the thing here's the thing so
you can
there are a lot of things that happened
in the sky that were never associated
with good events
like comets all right so could it have
been a comment no because
everyone says comets are bad at the time
uh and
other sorts of phenomena so could it
have been a supernova
well supernovas leave behind sort of
remnants of
their existence um we have what are
called supernova remnants
and we comb the sky for this and there's
no remnants plus
there's nobody else talking about it in
the sky at the time
the chinese were keeping really good
records of their night sky
astrologers were convinced that whatever
happened in the night sky was directly
affecting events on earth
and so you wanted to track such things
no one has any other records of it
so yeah we can't really reconcile it
with astronomical
uh phenomena interesting okay yeah
but but but but why stop there most of
what's in the bible is not reconcile
reconcilable just call them all miracles
and you're done
right okay i mean yeah yeah that's so
funny
just call them all yeah maybe the star
was only in the eyes of the three wise
men
you know i mean or whoever saw it but if
you're a non-believer you didn't see it
right there ways
are out of that right all right so
psychotropic drugs
okay if you are going to believe
that the creator of the universe
impregnated a virgin
giving birth to his son then
you don't need to appeal to actual
astronomical phenomenon
as the star of bethlehem
you know okay that kind of makes sense
it's like it's not a stretch
to just say this was in there they saw
this and it's in their minds
like a black storm trooper like how how
can you have a problem
seriously how are you gonna have a
problem with a black storm trooper
okay really so
you can suspend disbelief in a galaxy
far far away long long ago
but when it comes to a black storm
trooper that's too much
too much i got you i got what you're
saying i got what you say
only the star wars fans are gonna get
that one okay this is true
all right let's move on uh wait we only
did one question so far yeah we did
five questions wrapped in one okay all
right all right all right we got like
only a couple minutes left in this
segment all right a couple minutes this
is perfect
this is kyle marston and he writes it
just like this
how you know we only have eight planets
and that's like you need like someone
pressing against your chest right how do
you know now you know
okay all right here you go you ready go
ahead i
all right um we've sent spacecraft
from earth to the moon mars and beyond
spacecraft
that spacecraft that have traveled
through the asteroid belt and beyond
let's get the order here
again mercury venus earth mars the
asteroid
belt jupiter saturn uranus neptune
okay that's eight get over it so
how do we know there's only eight
planets well within
the world of these eight planets all
gravity is accounted for
so we know where all these objects are
and you can
run your equations that calculate the
force of gravity tugging on your
spacecraft
okay so as they move among the planets
and
enter orbit around saturn and go out to
pluto and wherever they're going
you factor in it because you want to
know where your spacecraft is and where
it's headed and where it's been
and and there's the initial thrust you
gave it
but then there's everybody tugging on it
you want to track that
so once you track it of the eight
planets
and whatever other objects you think
could be affecting it some comets maybe
if there's one nearby definitely the sun
once you do that there's not some
unexplainable
force operating on your spacecraft
so we don't need to appeal to some new
ninth planet that we haven't discovered
yet it could be
now if you want to go really far out in
the solar system and find an object
that's so far away it's not affecting
anything nearby
okay okay and in fact such work was done
there is an object suspected of being
way the hell out there far beyond
any zone we would call our solar system
historically like gold like three four
five times that size
and there might be a planet out there
that's affecting some comets all right
again we're looking at
its effect on other objects so
uh so maybe but is it let me let me give
you the
the street answer that if it's that far
away is it in the family
it's not in the family right there you
go right
right exactly are you the nice kid
if you're not if you're no right
no you're sleeping in the field right
not in the house
so it we might need another vocabulary
word
to account for objects that are so far
away
yet still part of the sun's family that
maybe there's just another word for them
i i don't know you want to call it a
planet fine
fine there you go but i i i call it
since you
since you brought up the planet i mean
the family i mean
if i told you once i'm telling remember
going to tell you again fredo don't ever
go against the family
was that the guy's name fredo yeah that
was his brother that was fredo oh it's
confusing with frodo yeah
i'm mixing my stories here yeah no i'm
talking sorry
that kind of family yeah gotham not lord
of the rings okay
all right then we would have to call the
planet samwise ganji it was
we gotta take a quick break when we come
back more cosmic queries grab bag
we're back cosmic aquarius galactic
gombol
that's what we're doing grab back no
grab bag
so we got to check how many ingredients
are in gumbo just to make sure because
maybe
we have more ingredients in this than
are actually found in gumbo itself
i told you that brings up the i i i i
ivan garnier is gumbo i'm gonna have to
i'm gonna
keep forgetting all right next time
we'll we'll straighten this out
because maybe we're insulting the gumbo
by putting too much in
or it's insulting us
so give me another another question uh
this is a velvet dunlop
velvet dunlap from that's it that's
somebody's name that's what they put man
so that's a movie star name is it really
from velvet
from uh spokane washington i was
wondering about the primary difference
of a gas giant and a typical star
during the formation from cosmic soup
is it just that there were more metals
or heavier gases in the formation of the
gas giant
that turned it into what it is
and i love that question it's it's an
origins question yes right
and so you go back to the gas cloud
right and by the way all stars are made
of gas
and gas clouds are prevalent in the
kinds of galaxies we live in a
flat spiral galaxy so it's it's not a
stretch to say
maybe stars are born in these gas clouds
you look in the gas clouds using special
telescopes because they're otherwise
opaque
you need telescopes where the
wavelengths of light can go
deep inside and when you do that you can
find
stellar nurseries even today
new stars are being born and so so
you look in there and you find out that
most stars being born are not
very massive in fact most stars are less
massive than the sun
all right those stars will turn out to
live for trillions of years but as you
sort of go up the mass
scale there are fewer and fewer and
fewer such stars and the most
massive of them there might only be one
or two of those made
in any cluster of stars in any sort of
star family and but otherwise there's no
difference it's made out of the same
ingredients
and the difference is it
happened to start out with slightly more
mass than everybody else
and if you have slightly more mass you
have more what energy check
uh gravity gravity thank you you have
mass and graph you have more gravity
more gravity you get in even more mass
and now you have even more mass you have
even more gravity
gravity and so there you go so it's kind
of a runaway for you
and so you win and everyone else gets
the drags
all right so this is how that works it's
it's how almost like capitalism really
yeah
look at that the ritz get richer
yeah poor bastards you know i might you
know
rewrite adam smith's the wealth of
nations in terms of the formation of
stars
the formation life death star by the way
that's a brilliant concept
and all joking aside however um yeah
that makes
perfect sense so it really is just that
like many things in life you
start out with a little bit more a
little bit
a little bit more makes you that much
more successful in life
look at that and those stars that
actually become
big like that they're called beyonce
stars
oh because of their luminosity that's
right not because of their mass
okay just trying to make sure that's all
i'm saying yeah
that's all right right not correct for
that all right that was a great question
i liked it all right
i learned something there so that was
cool by the way i heard uh david koch
one of the
now deceased koch brothers yes tell a
story
about how he brother billionaire
billionaire about how he
started in life and he tells the story
so when i started out
i had a newspaper run um on my bicycle
and i deliver newspapers every morning
and i got you know ten dollars a week
and i carefully put it in my bank
account
and i kept doing this through middle
school
and right up through high school and
then um when my father died i inherited
10 million dollars
that was a story that's hilarious
because that is amazing because that
is that's the origin story he was just
he's just up with it he just said yep
there it is you have it yeah other than
i started off
with a small loan of a million dollars
and then i got another bridge loan
of 100 million dollars and then before
you know it i'm a self-made man as a
billionaire
so all right here we go let's go to
howard chang
howard chang says hey i have a question
about
hawking radiation and how black holes
can theoretically
lose mass by ejecting particles
how's this even possible if nothing can
exceed the speed of light
in order to escape the event horizon of
the black hole
how fast you're throwing down the
supposed
particle trap throwing down
oh my boy here is paying attention
and he's he's he's not letting anything
go by
all right now what i'm about to tell you
when i first learned it
completely blew my mind all right cool
okay
all right you ready ready the black hole
is not ejecting these particles
which have been called hawking radiation
that's not what's actually happening
okay
okay what's actually happening is
just outside of the event horizon okay
within which nothing escapes right all
right
the the black hole gravity is all
throughout the space there it's it's not
only
inside the event horizon it's outside
the event and it continues onward all
right
but just outside the event horizon the
gravitational energy
is still sufficiently high
that spontaneously matter is created
from it
okay because okay e equals
m m c squared so that's so if you mass
and energy back and forth back and forth
it's a
two-way street so if you have a high
enough concentration of energy
you can start popping particles into
existence
and it looks like they're coming out of
a thin air out of thin air
but or thin space so the cost of this
is that the total amount of
gravitational energy
has diminished by that ever small amount
and if you're going to make particles
out of thin air you will always make a
pair of particles somebody got a pattern
like somebody gotta pay somewhere
somebody's gotta pay
so you're gonna make two one is gonna be
matter the other is gonna be anti-matter
and they're gonna be flying apart in the
exact opposite directions
so that's the just the physics of it and
it happens all the time so
don't sweat that so watch what happens
this particle gets created
right outside the event horizon one
direction goes back into the event
horizon
and the and the other direction goes out
and it escapes the system
that particle that escapes is taking
mass away from the black hole itself and
you might say but i thought the black
hole is inside the event horizon no the
black hole is the entire
system including the gravitational
energy that
manifests it what and
the inventory of these particles that
come out of the gravitational energy
get take your inventory how many quarks
how many protons neutrons electrons take
your inventory
it will exactly equal
what the black hole had eaten and pulled
into its event horizon originally damn
so the the the gravitational
field has a memory of what the black
hole
ate this is profound this is more than
profound that's some creepy trippy stuff
right there it's creepy
it's creepy yeah yes so the black hole
is losing
mass that it had long ago consumed
out of the energy the gravitational
energy field that it has created
in its environment and for some reason
what's outside of that
hole outside of the the horizon event
horizon
has an inventory checklist of what had
crossed the event horizon
event horizon and it's taken them out
one by one oh my gosh
that is that's beyond amazing
yeah and so it's what it means is you
don't lose information
that had fallen into the black hole the
information content of what stuff is
made of and by the way so you might say
well how do i know this did i go to the
black hole and check it
no this is no i met a friend article and
the particle told me
he said what kind of particle are you
he's like yo i escaped the system
all right i escaped the system
i busted out
oh snap so that's kind of i mean it's
sort of
what happened there that's sort of so
it's free and it goes off to you know
having encounters with other objects in
the universe
wow so this process is slow so hawking
radiation this evaporation of black
holes
takes very a very long time and
you know longer than the current age of
the universe so you're not going to wait
around for this
to for it to completely evaporate but
so hawking showed this and later
research
showed that these particles do remember
what was inside
and that's applying the very well tested
concepts
of of quantum physics wow that's
yeah dope that's all i could say
that's dope damn yeah so cool all right
let's move on
hey hey speaking of dope there's a movie
called dope did you know this i did not
yeah yeah there's a movie called dope
about a kid who's really nerdy
okay uh uh in high school but the gangs
want him to join the gangs
but he's you know but he's getting like
a straight a's and he wants to go to
like harvard and but there's all these
forces operating on him and he's just
trying to deal
with it and and i get name check i get
name checked in the movie
get out of here yeah are you like his
buddy or something
no no he's
i have another nerd friend he's going to
be an astrophysicist
he's he writes some essay i think it's
for his english class
and the guy criticizes it and he said
what did you write here
and he says oh yeah this is the story
if it were written by neil degrasse
tyson it was some funny
because the english teacher wasn't fully
embracing his
sci-fi creativity in the in the class or
something so but anyhow
there's a movie called it's called dope
all right all right a part comedy but
part serious social
commentary exactly okay all right go on
here we go this is eric
gross eric says this hey stark talk team
have a question i've always come back to
that's worthy of deep thought
given that energy and matter are
equivalent and all existence as we know
it is a subjective
interpretation of infinite interactions
of matter and energy
do modern theorists believe that
anything
like free will or self-determination
is likely to exist
oh i have an answer for that oh get out
of it how the hell do you have an answer
for that
after the break when we come back
when we come back to stark talk god's
aquarius
all right we're back
cosmic queries the the the kitchen sink
edition
uh questions now called from our patreon
supporters thank you i
publicly thank you for that your
interest and your participation
in making this highly successful variant
of our star talk broadcast fun to do
and happy to serve so check
okay here we go we we left off with a
deep question
uh and what is it if matter equals
energy
and all the world is a subjective
infinite interactions between matter and
energy do modern theorists believe
anything like free will or
self-determination is likely to
exist now who asked this question yeah
tell me about it
uh his name is aristotle his name is i
smoke weed
every day no it's
this is frost smoke weed this is from
his name
every day i smoke weed jokes smoke weed
johnson
no this is eric gross what a great great
eric gross that's a clean simple name
but name like that shouldn't be having
thoughts this deep you need a different
name for that
uh i agree chuck we'll come back with a
different name
so anyhow so first of all uh number one
it is true so the your first given is
accurate
that a matter of energy or equivalent
as provided by equals mc squared your
second
given i'm not giving you you're trying
to say the whole world is an unfolding
of subjectively
interpreted events you you could get
away with that
before science was invented but we
invented science
to separate our
sensory system from the thing that's
doing the actual measurements
of what's going on in the world so
instead of using your eyes we use a
telescope instead of using a mic
your your eyes the other way we use a
microscope and we take
measurements of this we we no longer
rely
on your brain eye
ear connection to
either take data or report the data okay
when you do this you can now establish
objective realities that are not
filtered through your subjective
system of your subjective sensory system
and so so that's why science works
that's why the question
if a tree falls in the forest and no one
is there to hear it did it make sound
yeah if you don't know anything about
science right yeah that's a really great
question philosophical questions
okay but i can put chart recorders there
i can measure vibrations i can
do things that establish the existence
of sound
independent of your sensory system yeah
and by the way just falling in a forest
that no one is there to hear
makes this sound okay just go ahead
and it's only when no one's there to
hear it
but one of my favorite gary larson
comics was in the barn
and there's a chicken a horse a pig and
you know the farmer is somewhere else
and they're all talking and
and i forgot who said what but
was it the pig one of them said but if
you divide by the square root of mass
you get the same result
and then the chicken said but you're
missing the basic premise of my theory
and then someone looks out the window
and says farmer and then the farmer
shows up
that's funny it's like as a scientist
i'm kind of hoping that's really going
on in the barn
you know even though i i don't really
believe it i want it to be true right
so so point is i'm not giving you that
can't have that
that there's that the whole world is
somehow subjectively unfolding so now
how about free will a lot of recent work
on this especially
in the neuroscience community all right
and they're finding things like you're
sitting in a room
and they got the electrodes on your head
and they
and and they find
electrical activity and
that precedes your conscious awareness
of a thought that you then have and then
act on that thought
okay so you'll say things like i'm going
to stand
up right now and then you stand up you
think you came up with that thought
at the moment you think you came up with
that thought but
brain scans and sensors tell you that
that
was already a thought in progress
so our conscious awareness of free will
is not actually free will
something else is going on
subconsciously wow yeah okay so now you
can ask
what is making the subconscious do its
thing
if you're not aware of it but you after
the fact declare that you
made this decision on your own then
then what does free will even mean right
so so that's the that's a line of
questioning
that's coming back into that world and
the neuroscientists are right on top of
it maybe we'll do a whole
a whole episode just on free will to get
to the bottom of that be very clear
because i'm only sharing with you what
i've heard and read and spoken with
some experts on it um so but that being
said
i even if it's not real
i fully enjoy my illusion of free will
right right i you know and and take it
all the way maybe we're in a simulation
and all of this is already sort of
programmed in
and i'm going to thank the programmer
for not
telling me that i don't have free will
because i like enjoying
the the idea that i do and if everyone
is operating on that assumption
uh what i i'd wonder of what value is it
to even contemplate
whether you don't hmm
well you could do it philosophically
legally right you can say oh my gosh
this person robbed the bank
but they were not of their own free will
well in some respects what you just said
there
is there are some examples of that and i
will say that
drug addiction is one so there are
people who feel like oh well you know
all you have to do is stop doing drugs
but what they don't realize is that when
you do drugs you break your brain
so that the stopping part does
not it no longer works yes same with
alcohol
exactly right and and you dupe yourself
you start making excuses right and you
your brain starts
taking control over your own power
of decision and action so that's a whole
that's a whole future of the world that
we need to analyze
to try to resolve and understand and
possibly
cure if in fact that's how we're going
to
get into our own brains so yeah
very cool very cool so did i i don't
know if i did i fully yeah you did
i mean the fact that the real answer to
the question
is uh stop making assumptions
about the infinite interactions between
matter and energy
that equate to a subjective interpret
interpretation of the entire universe
because that
that is not the case that's that's the
real answer
that is not that's not the case okay
there's also quantum physics where
things are not deterministic they're
probabilistic right
and so you cannot know exactly what will
happen you'll only know
probabilistically what will happen
and and what's interesting in quantum
physics is even though
there are these uncertainties that guide
what's happening
we precisely quantify what those
uncertainties are
wow so so we can we can quantify
our uncertainty that's a head trip which
sounds
that's a head trip right there right
there
it's primarily because these are systems
of many many particles and statistics
come out basically perfectly the bigger
the system is we are 100
sure that we are unsure exactly
that's not what i said
okay all right all right let's next one
[Laughter]
all right here we go uh let's go to
nathan kane what's up nathan he says
this what's the possibility that we
could one day
use stars as an alchemy table of sorts
to forge elements for ourselves and then
extract them
ooh interesting i like where he's going
with that
exactly ooh so so we just so what we're
saying is i need more gold
all right so let's just churn the the
nuclear furnace
right and and you could tap the star
like you tap a keg
right and you put it in the right spot
where the gold was being made take it
out and you have your gold atoms
uh that's that's fast that would be a
really cool sci-fi novel
yeah i think yeah yeah uh it's just that
so much of the rest of the star is doing
things that
you don't care about so the fusion is
going on only deep down in the core
and it needs to be in the core because
that's where the high pressures are from
all the stuff that's not otherwise doing
anything else
what i might imagine is if you have the
power enough to tap a star
you could just build some kind of
particle machine
you know in your backyard if this is the
future and just have it churn out the
gold by fusing enough atoms together
and that's its only job is to do that
rather than be a star
in addition to making heavy elements so
in that future that's what i would try
to invent
or what you've talked about in the past
is
you can just mine asteroids that
often thank you will already have those
elements
inside of the pieces thank you chuck
i didn't even think to me to say that
you're coming along you you're going to
get an
honorary degree when this is all done i
just want you to say all right
so it's exactly right because landing on
an asteroid
you don't risk vaporizing yourself as
you would
trying to get into a star so yes all of
those heavy ingredients
were scattered back into the universe
and have collected and been
pre-sifted to make these
metallic asteroids where you have the
platinum the iridium the gold the silver
the the the iron the nickel all of it's
there
so yeah chuck cool all right yeah okay
so just because you can do it that way
doesn't mean you should there might be
other simpler ways but it's it's i like
the way his brain is thinking
yes all right let's go to steven's
spotted horse
and steven spotted horse says hello dr
tyson and mr nice steven spotted horse
here from
oklahoma why is gravity
so weird of a force we are also familiar
with it
it keeps being it keeps our feet on the
ground and yes so much weaker than other
forces is it possible
that there are other dimensions we
cannot observe
and gravity our gravity could just be
escaping into these other dimensions
therefore
diluting the force of the gravity that
we experience
making it so weak but yet it's really
not
we would be able to receive
gravitational forces from other
dimensions in space
wow these people today are really man
they're smoking something
together they all got together just like
yo man you ever realize that maybe that
we're dealing with an
infinite number of possibilities
that really i make so excited we don't
have any kind of true
will or free whip nah man here's what i
want to know
why is gravity so weak i mean seriously
it's like the strongest force in the
universe but yet at the same time i can
break it
just by jumping off the ground
that's some deep deep [ __ ] man
all right let me see if i can answer
that in the remaining
90 seconds all right so spotted horse
here we go uh gravity
is the weirdest of the four basic forces
it's the weirdest because it is by far
the weakest all right the weakest
force so and just bend down and pick up
a paper clip off the ground you just
you just resisted the gravity of the
earth by pulling it away from the earth
the earth could not hold it against just
the strength of your muscles
so so that it's weak
and there's because of how gravity
behaves and how einstein describes it
maybe we shouldn't think of it as a
force at all
interesting because if gravity is only
how you are responding
to the curvature of space and time
as einstein said it was an einstein or
one of his students
john archibald wheeler one of the two of
them said
gravity matter tells space how to curve
and space tells matter how to move
so they've got this sort of two-way
street there and
if you're just moving along a curved
surface is that really a force
do you get is that should you call it a
force
of rank and privilege of the other
forces that we know so that's a
legitimate question to ask
and if it's not a force that would
explain why it doesn't really
play well in the sandbox with the rest
of the other forces
now are there higher dimensions in which
gravity manifests differently yeah there
could be
and you know my favorite explanation for
dark matter which is really dark gravity
which is not
what the professional physicist experts
are betting on
but i just kind of like it because it's
fun that maybe
this mysterious source of gravity in our
universe
that has no known source is actually
ordinary matter
in a parallel universe with its gravity
spilling into ours
right and we see oh there's a mysterious
force of gravity where is it from i
don't know
and it's a big mystery and whereas in
another universe they just have ordinary
objects
with spillage so yeah this is unknown
it's unknown but i think the more we can
learn about parallel universes
um the more we might be able to think
about how
the universes may go bump in the night
and possibly
alert each other to their presence
uh in one way or another wow so yeah i
like the way he's thinking yeah
it's kind of cool it's a cool thought
cool thought
and and mr spotted horse invite chuck
and me to your next
uh session next week
next time you guys all get together
oh yeah okay yeah so i think that's all
we have time for
all right well let me just say hello
these were some deep questions this
weekend
and we still didn't get to quite a few
so but don't worry guys we're going to
get to your questions so
always good to have you chuck tweeting
at chuck nice comment thank you sir yes
always good
and if anybody's looking i i hardly ever
announce this but i tweet at
neil tyson really because you only have
15 million people
on i think they already knew that bro
all right all right this has been star
talk cosmic queries kitchen sink edition
and i'm your host neil degrasse tyson
your personal astrophysicist
keep looking up
you